the price of the rise of macron has been
the destruction of the mainstream right
and the mainstream left
so if as Mr Shirak did if he was to call
parliamentary elections I think again as
Jonathan alluded to it the main
beneficiaries would be the extreme left
and the extreme right particularly the
extreme right both the extreme left and
the extreme right are against the
pension reforms so there isn't even a
political way out of this either which I
think which is why France is interesting
I mean our own prime minister Mr sunac
he's delayed the pension raising the
pension age again the reason people
should watch carefully what's happening
in France is because it is important the
the issues are alive all over Europe
like this at the moment they're just at
their most acute in France for